We've all heard the saying "painting on a smile."
Well, one Japanese artist has taken that phrase to a whole new level.
Nobumichi Asai has found a way to project and map expressions onto people's faces,...
...effectively creating a facial mask.
He and his team displayed their three-dimensional facial projection mapping system...
...to a select group of spectators in Tokyo.
The team drew inspiration from the sense of beauty...
...inherent in traditional Japanese culture, animation and technology.
But they quickly discovered that simply projecting a totally symmetrical face...
...seen typically in video games would produce a Barbie doll look,...
...killing the realism,...
...so they instead designed a face asymmetrically, introducing subtle flaws.